Republican Senator Lindsey Graham has become
one of the most pernicious Republican senators.
Part of why he is so slippery is that Lindsey
Graham knows how to every once in a while
behave sort of normally despite being mostly
an incompetent and dangerous buffoon who sucks
up to Trump at every opportunity.
And so, as an example, last week, Lindsey
Graham gave a speech during the late at night
when the count of the electoral vote had resumed
after the armed insurrection was quelled,
at least temporarily.
Lindsey Graham gave a very reasonable sounding
speech saying, listen, I supported this president
and I wanted him to win, but this strategy
isn't going to work and that strategy isn't
going to work.
And in the end, the reason we're here is mostly
perfunctory and we have no choice but to say
Joe Biden is the next president.
And a lot of people said, oh, OK, not bad
golf clap.
He's he's making some sense.
And within just a couple of days of that,
Lindsey Graham appears on Fox News begging
for mercy for Trump to avoid being impeached
or removed.
Just pathetic.
Lindsey Graham begging.
Look at this.
I'm calling on Vice President Biden to pick
up the phone and call Nancy Pelosi and the
squad to end the second impeachment.
President Trump gave a statement last night
that was helpful.
It hit the mark.
He wants to move on to a peaceful transfer
of power.
He wants this to end calling on Biden to call
Nancy Pelosi.
What in just those first 20 seconds Lindsey
is talking about, he's making statements riddled
with lies and distortions.
He wants Biden to call Pelosi.
The House of Representatives must determine
if Trump's behavior is worthy of impeachment.
If it is, the House must impeach.
It's their responsibility and it is their
duty.
I don't want nor need Joe Biden calling Nancy
Pelosi to influence her one way or the other.
If you said, hey, Joe should call Nancy to
encourage her to impeach now, he should know
he shouldn't.
The decision on impeachment is for the House
of Representatives, period.
Second, you know, Lindsey says Trump made
a helpful statement and committed to a peaceful
transfer.
Trump was essentially forced out there to
say the equivalent of now that I've burned
the whole house down, I promise not to light
anymore matches.
And he did it under duress, under duress,
excuse me.
And he didn't even mean it, as evidenced by
the tweets that he sent immediately after.
So 20 seconds.
Disgusting from Lindsey.
Let's look at the end of what he had to say.
I'm calling on Vice President elect Biden
to pick up the phone and call Nancy Pelosi
and the squad to end the second impeachment.
President Trump gave a statement last night
that was helpful.
It hit the mark.
He wants to move on to a peaceful transfer
of power.
He wants this to end.
I've been with him most of the day.
He's going to focus on his agenda, his successes
for the American people in the next few days.
But Joe Biden said it's up to Congress regarding
impeachment.
No President elect Biden is up to you.
Pick up the phone, call Nancy Pelosi, Chuck
Schumer and the squad and tell them, stand
down.
This will destroy.
The country even further, you have the power
to do that.
The question is, do you have the courage to
do it?
Joe Biden was right.
It's up to Congress.
Lindsay is a disgusting Trump tool.
And also, by the way, again, with the meme
of this will be divisive and it will further
destroy the country.
I'm sick of the hypocrisy and this opportunist
nonsense from from these people.
Whenever they are the ones causing the disunity,
they say this is a time to come together.
We need unity whenever they are out of power
and can't do anything, anything as they will
be in just a few days.
They say, well, now we need bipartisanship
whenever anger and wanting consequences for
actions turns against them because of their
radical behavior.
Like last week, they caused us to get to this
point.
And now they say, oh, we need calm.
And now that they've been as divisive as anyone
in history in the United States, they say,
oh, impeachment would be divisive.
Now, impeachment's required.
The divisive acts are the ones that warrant
impeachment.
When the facts say you must impeach, you must
impeach.
And by the way.
Had Republican senators like Lindsey Graham.
Voted to convict Donald Trump on impeachment
the first time the riot never would have happened,
and those same Republican senators now think
they get to tell us whether Trump should be
impeached a second time.
It's pathetic, Lindsey constantly playing
both sides.
And by the way, the sick irony of it failing.
Lindsay has been trying to play both sides
for years and he's been trying to do it over
the last four days as well.
It failed.
Lindsay sort of gave a mildly reasonable speech
on the floor of the House during that joint
session on what was it, Wednesday night, very
early Thursday morning.
But then he still is begging for mercy for
Trump and defending Trump.
But he was at the airport at the end of last
week getting ready to get on a plane.
And he had to have police protection because
the Magga Trump people were screaming traitor,
traitor, traitor and surrounding Lindsey Graham.
So it's so pathetic that even his mealy mouthed
hypocrisy and playing both sides has not spared
him the ire from the same riotous insurrectionists
who stormed the Capitol last week.
And it it all has to end.
There are such bigger issues here that need
to be dealt with in this country to really
get this insanity under control.
Widespread ignorance as a virus, the mind
virus of ignorance and lack of media literacy
is part of the problem.
We'll keep talking about the bigger picture
issues, but what a pathetic clown Lindsey
Graham has really become
The David Pakman Show
at David Pakman Dotcom.